foreign
Madison is with us in Columbus Ohio hey
Madison welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi George it's an honor and a
privilege uh long time listener first
time caller well thank you how can we
help today
um it's actually a career question I'm
27 years old I'm a registered nurse I
just left my specialty of seven years
for what I thought was my dream job
I thought I was leaving for a job that
was a perfect fit and I was super
excited to start but I'm slowly
realizing that it's a very toxic work
environment and it's not what I signed
up for I've pretty much decided that
it's not a good fit for me mentally and
physically I'm just asking of how I need
to proceed to leave on the best terms
possible
wow I'm sorry
thank you um
you got another gig you can go to
obviously in nursing right
yes yes and I'm trying to find something
that I'm honestly passionate about I
think the most frustrating part about
all of this is that I really felt like I
put the time into real uh
making sure that this was a good fit
into my career what'd you miss I'm sorry
what did you miss
leadership leadership I think that's my
biggest problem right now and that's
something that I can't change you know
I'm just thinking if I if you know I'm
trying to if you stepped in a trap once
before I would want to know what that
trap looks like and smells like if
you're going if you're going through the
forest again right
yes and I do feel like I've learned a
lot in this experience it's just I need
to leave it's not a good fit okay
how would you describe the environment
you're saying it's a toxic workplace
there's not good leadership what does
that look like in the day to day
chaos I really feel
um kind of the back story of this is
that um the person that is training me
he actually fired and I am now expected
to step into this position too many icky
things have happened and I just don't
feel right about it you know it's just
not who I want to be working under as
somebody who wants to be in a leadership
position
they're struggling with communication
they're struggling with organizational
skills
um so we know you know who they are and
um you cannot control how they react
although we can fairly predict it
yeah I mean who you just described to me
is probably not going to react with
class
no and I've already seen it yeah so
um that doesn't change who you are it
changes it just States who they are and
so the only the only thing you can do is
a don't expect an alligator to do
anything but be an alligator
number one so don't set your
expectations this regardless of what you
do that somehow you're going to make
these people be something other than
toxic because they're probably going to
react in a toxic manner just be ready
for that brace yourself right
um that doesn't Define you that defines
them and that doesn't uh also on the
second part of the equation then is it
also doesn't uh dictate how you handle
this you handle this not based on them
but based on you
you're a person of class
you're a person of Integrity uh and so
you're going to be that person here and
so you're going to be calm
and kind and direct
and they're by the way there's no reason
to critique them on the way out it will
do no good
nope nope
nope that's just standard exit interview
crap that they're not going to take the
advice or they would have already been
doing all these things
foreign
don't believe in exit interviews we do
them at Ramsey because a bunch of my
leadership team disagrees with me and I
acquiesce and let them do them but I
don't need an exit interview I'm staying
I'm going to keep it being who I am and
I don't really give a crap what your
opinion is if you're leaving so I'm that
that's me that may be toxic but it is
what it is I'm I'm staying you're not so
why do I care what you think you know so
anyway besides that these people aren't
going to listen
and you're not you're no longer my point
of that whole rant was you're not in a
position of credibility once you've quit
to influence decisions there the only
way you got you can influence decisions
there is stay in with your shoulder to
the wheel but once you've decided to
leave you're not in a position of
influence
so do what's best for me and my family
yeah very quickly quietly calmly
with as few sentences and as few things
in writing as possible other than just
thank you for the opportunity this whole
situation is just different than I
thought it was it doesn't line up with
the way I think and I just I can't do
this and I am so sorry
um and gosh thank you for letting me try
and thank you for the opportunity and
I've just I've accepted a thing at
another place bye and it's just really
really really really short
thank you so much I have this this gave
me a lot of guidance yeah just be very
very
kind and quiet and quick
um there's no the decisions made there's
nothing that's going to change the
decision by having a long discussion and
you're going to get drawn into
their web of garbage if you start having
a discussion about it
because you're gone thank you you're
gone you already told me you're gone
there's nothing they can do that'll make
you stay right
yes yeah so the decision's made it's
just now a matter of executing it and
again uh you're a person of Class A
person of Integrity so leave with lots
of class and smile and grateful thank
you for letting me try this I'm so sorry
it didn't work out
um and gosh I wish you guys the best I
hope everything works well and
you know good luck with your toxic bad
self and so
a lot of people feel like I owe my
employer all of this when I'm leaving
and so it's like a breakup when you're a
teenager you don't want to drag it out
and make it this big emotional process
if it's done it's done and it's we have
to be adults and just move on and you
know truthfully the same is true on the
other side of the coin uh the way we
train leadership here on the way we
train entree leaders is
if you're going to work with someone and
give that person a bunch of input
do that before you fire them
you know so I'm gonna we're gonna work
together
we're gonna have some difficult
conversations and say this activity this
Behavior this attitude uh whatever it is
that has to change you know you're going
to do better you're going to prosper if
you adopt these character qualities you
know we're going to walk with you and
help you and Coach you uh and if you
don't then you can't be a we because we
do it this way and so we're going to
talk about being a we talk about it talk
about it talk about it talk about it but
once we've decided that that the
relationship as far as employment is
going to end uh the exit for the person
is about a minute and a half long as
quickly as possible it's just uh you
know we've been talking about this and
I'm so sorry but we we don't think it's
going to work anymore and today's your
last day and so uh HR will help you with
the paperwork and we're going to give
you we've agreed to give you a severance
of this much and uh gosh any way we can
help you out there in the world we'll
help you any way we can but we don't
believe that there's a change is going
to happen anymore and boom it's I mean
quitters do not survive that Dave no
it's we we don't do it's very very loud
in a not in the sense of yelling but
it's very crystal clear and long before
we got to
uh quiet firing or it wouldn't be quiet
firing it would be uh loud firing a
direct clear firing there we go long
before we got that with a quiet quitter
we would have had these discussions like
coaching and you know this idea plan
mediocrity is your goal you ain't a Wii
we don't do mediocrity We're Going For
Excellence we're trying to win the Super
Bowl so you're not going to fit in we we
we go for it and so if you want to be a
Wii you got to go for it and we would
have had that discussion and then we
would have the quiet quitting would have
ceased